how are you sir good morning rich I'm
doing well great to chat with you so
let's uh let's start with how is life
for you coach it's been a it's been a
while since we've chatted well it's it's
very good I spend the winters in Florida
and the summers in Saratoga in New York
you know I'm pretty active in horse
racing and I enjoy that very much I need
action and that's some of it and then I
play golf and pretty much in good health
so I'm enjoying my time now okay why is
there action on the golf course to coach
there maybe a little okay maybe a little
all right what's your game like what
does it look like right now your golf
game
Wow you know when you're 77 you can't
hit it as far and it's I'm struggling
right now comparatively speaking to what
I used to be able to do I'm struggling
but I enjoy the game I enjoy the
competition and I still like practicing
hitting golf balls and things so you
know it's not tedious at all for me
fantastic what is me something to do
what's the best round you ever had and
where the best round I ever had was 72
at due-process
stable in Colts Neck New Jersey called
snack that was a long time ago will you
coaching the Jets Giants at the time
which one were you coaching at the time
no I don't know to the best of my
recollection I'm not sure I just know it
was a long time ago and both of those
things were a long time let's talk about
the hearing now then some of your guys
from your coaching tree quite active in
not just coaching but trying to win a
Super Bowl this year and I'd love to
start if you don't mind with Mike Zimmer
since he's the one who bounced his
offensive coordinator with three games
to go I'm wondering what you think the
challenges of that are going to be for a
six six and one team with a new
quarterback this year and obviously a
new play caller for the last three games
well I think these kinds of things are
difficult to do at best and I'm pretty
sure that it was just something that
wasn't working and might probably didn't
want to forego the season and he wanted
to try to do something about it now you
know and if right now they're still in
the I think the wild card slot and if
they could win three games I think that
would insure them a playoff and then of
course you starting over so I think it
he thought that it was worthwhile to try
to do something I don't know the the
inner workings of it but I'm sure there
was something that wasn't satisfactory
or you would've done it so what is the
challenges do you think for the last
three weeks or do you think that could
actually work to their advantage that
other teams can't Scout them they don't
know what's coming potentially well you
know I think probably the the people
that are still there I don't think the
offense will change appreciably but I
think they'll they'll try to maybe put a
little more emphasis in a couple areas
that they've been deficient in and you
know take a look at themselves and see
what they exactly think they can do they
should know that pretty much by this
time of the season but anytime you make
change there's a little uncertainty
particularly on your game day management
and you know you have a new play call or
you know ease how much does the head
coach involved and he'll be involved I'm
sure so that's that's some of the
challenges more so I think the game day
management bill parcells hall-of-famer
here on the Rich Eisen show was the
first time you had Sean Payton and what
you see in him you know something that's
a that's a really good question the
first time I ever met him is when we
flew together to Dallas to go to the
Cowboys I had never met him in person
before that I had talked well several
times over the phone and I hired him
over the phone over the phone what so
what did you I guess what you would you
hearing him then
to say okay that's my Isaac ball first
of all he'd been with the Giants and I
have you know at that point I had quite
a few reference points with some of the
people that I've interacted with with
the Giants and they had very good things
to say about him and particularly some
people that I was close to with the
Giants thought he was a good young coach
and just the circumstance there that
happens to some young coaches from time
to time and but they thought he had good
potential and they were right well I
certainly were and you know he's he
seems to me his old-school throwback as
they come and yet he has absolutely gone
with the flow if you will these days
with offenses and what to do and having
an old warhorse at quarterback in this
day and age where you need one of those
young kids on a first contract it seems
he could pay all the other guys around
and what he's been able to do is is
truly something else I'm wondering how
how much do you think the experience
from Dallas or other experiences of
playing into all of us oh I think is you
know he's one of the most tenured
coaches in the league now and your
experience can do nothing but help you
and I remember having them having a
discussion with him a few years back
that from his championship team he was
going to have to recycle pretty much
completely all the man his quarterback
which is fortunate and that's what he's
been able to do he's been able to put
new lineman new defensive players new
secondary players new receivers you know
new runners and it's it's been a great
transition for him and it's allowed him
to continue to be very very strong
offensively and Sean is not a he's
old-school I think in terms of what he
how he wants this game to behave but
he's very open minded and about the
future and and new ideas and things like
that he likes those things and and
enjoys implementing them and if he feels
like his team could
execute them I'm sure you've noticed the
state of the game has been trending more
offensively coach what what do you think
is the counterbalance to that even
though we have seen some defensive
battles certainly with the Bears and the
Rams just this past weekend what do you
think the counterbalance is or will we
see one in the NFL you know it's
obviously what the NFL wants it wants
scoring there's no doubt about it they
think flooring sells and they might be
right
I think they've put limitations by the
new rules on the kicking game which used
to be I mean it's still vital but it's
certainly not as preeminent as it used
to be because there aren't that many
punt return or kickoff return
opportunities and you know the field
goal rule has put a little intrigue in
the game and I mean the extra point rule
is put a little entry in the game there
but that part of the game is appreciably
different and you know the rules also as
you know are pretty much stacked to
ensure offensive continuity I mean every
single defensive penalty but offsides
results in a first down and so that's
given the offense there's a lot more
opportunities and you know it's just the
percentage thing the more opportunities
you get the higher percentage you're
gonna have in scoring so that's what
they want but still in the end you know
when the elements get into play like you
know since eotl in Chicago some of these
contending teams now and they get into
play and certainly New England the
elements are a great equalizer
and when it's a windy day and cold and
and the flags are cracking you know all
those passing offenses a lot of the time
don't don't execute as well so defenses
I still think very very important and if
you can you know get some stops once in
a while then it gives you a good chance
I think these offense and these
high-flying offenses which we've got
really got a couple ago um so one or two
of them defensively our little suspect
and so I think on on the right day they
could be had in the playoffs and you
know it's it's one of those things where
you're not gonna out score everybody all
the time and but that's the way they
want the game now and that's the way it
is and it's just exciting I mean I
enjoyed those games last weekend did you
remark did you enjoy that 54-51 mundane
ardor between the Chiefs and the Rams
you know a defensive coordinator at
heart I had a hard time with that one
you know I don't think I don't think the
coordination really like seeing those
cookies yeah and waiting Bob Sutton her
old school - I mean those guys are the
diesel oh that's right yeah no you see
Vic Fangio what he did the other night
right daran Chicago he's always been a
top coordinator in and you see what a
good defense could do even with an
offense that's that's kind of iffy on
scoring points and but there are they're
in contention and strong I would say get
a game in Chicago it'll be tough did you
see that exchange between the media and
Bill Belichick the week before the
run-up to the Bears playing the Patriots
and somebody was talking about Khalil
Mack being a game wrecker maybe an all
time game wrecker and attempted to say
the words Lawrence Taylor in the same
sentence and Belichick stop that
reporter right there goes no no no no
hold on a second that's Lawrence Taylor
you're talking about did you see that
exchange I did yeah and in fact Lawrence
called me and we discussed that can you
uh can you enlighten us on the details
of that conversation you had with LT Wow
he said he said I think I could command
a pretty good salary these days what he
told me like that but you know
Mack has been a good addition for
Chicago and he's a very good player I
think he's gotten a lot of recognition
um but you know there's 11 or 12 guys
that have more sex than him and you know
people there's a there's a young guy in
Denver that Brazi job I mean I haven't
heard anybody mentioned his name he's
he's a tremendous rookie and he's got 12
and a half sacks already with three
games to go
a rookie getting 15 sacks maybe you know
that's very very unusual hmm
so what switch is the most complete team
you think right now coach Marcel's the
few minutes to have left with you here
Super Bowl right around the corner three
games to go in the regular season the
most complete team in the NFL the
complete team I think probably New
Orleans they're playing pretty good on
defense but I am very leery of the teams
that seem to have the assets in place
like Dallas in Seattle today are
improving at a very very fast rate now
and when you look across the board on
Dallas now they have firepower at the
receiver position with Gallup and Cooper
their runner they have a quarterback
that can get the job done they get
better play out of their tight ends last
week their defensive front is excellent
they have good linebackers too young
linebackers that are very good I think
they're gonna be a tough out as well and
you I mean you can judge a space that on
them hanging in there with New Orleans
the other night
so you see Chicago with the Bears and
Dallas with New Orleans and Seattle with
Minnesota and you got a figure that
they're going to be a factor once they
if they could get in then there's also
another assistant of yours here in Los
Angeles and Anthony Lynn when Melvin
Gordon comes back you could make the
case the Chargers of the most complete
team as well well you know something you
mentioned what I think for the Chargers
is the key piece Melvin Gordon I think
with him there take out a real shot
without him I think it's a little
problematic because it gets a little too
one-sided on the passer and you know it
doesn't give him that bow
that they that and they need that
defensively they they're playing pretty
well so it's it I think it'll be an
interesting game uh here soon and it'll
be uh they'll be very interesting yeah I
mean and you know what you mentioned
with Dallas Amari Cooper when they
acquired him for a first-round selection
or drafted late in Vander Esch instead
of Calvin Ridley a lot of people were
wondering if Jerry Jones had lost his a
mind or could not shop for groceries but
he kind of made the right moves there
wouldn't you say yes he did in fact they
probably give two ones for almost I do
what he was going through my bad
you know he's he's done well and that
Gallup has been a factor for them he's
he's a speed factor it they've got two
guys I can run outside that's a big
thing you like listening Romo in the
booth coach oh yeah he's a piece of work
is man he is
I heard him the other day that's right
at the last second was I think it was
the Ravens and the Chiefs in but Ravens
needed that close first down and Griffin
was in there and he starts calling my
offensive plays we said oh they're gonna
run a little go special and sure enough
that's what the here a Deewani that's
one plays huh that's one of your plays
well that won him what he meant was
sixty two all go special yeah that's
what late yeah that's what he meant
I know what he meant yeah so a couple a
couple more four-year coach Parcells
before I let you head off to the I guess
it's the winner so you're down in
Florida right now or you're not with the
ponies yeah okay alright so what happens
if let's just say Peyton
Sean Peyton and this the Saints take on
Bill Belichick and the Patriots in the
Super Bowl just the X's and O's and just
you know on these guys what type of game
do you think we'd see because it sure
looks like we could get all with breezin
potentially well that would be very
exciting I think you see two dynamic TAS
offenses in
probably you know New England's always
gonna have a good kicking game built
puts a lot of emphasis on that and I
think Sean's got a couple of good
special teams players down there that
pace until he's done some things for him
and so I'm gonna be very interesting but
again it goes back to who can stop who
the most times and I think that's what
it would be I think it'd be a very
exciting Super Bowl and that would be
okay with me as well okay yeah you're
just watching two of your your guys I
guess in a way former assistants go at
it right there and what do you think of
when you see Patrick mahomes coach you
were talking about you were watching
that game some of the throws he was
making a no-look one across them in over
the middle and then the fourth and nine
one to win what do you think of when you
see that kid listen I think he's
spectacular but I I have to really pay
tribute to Andy Reid on this team he
knew that he wanted Patrick Holmes he
traded up to get him and then he had the
patience to hold him in abeyance for a
year while he learned and got his feet
on the ground I got the feel for
professional football and looked at the
defenses and sat there as a spectator
for a whole year and I think so many
times now these quarterbacks come up
everybody wants to see them and then
they they rationalize it but well we got
to find out what we got well sometimes
when you throw these kids to the Wolves
you can destroy them and there's been a
lot of cases of that but Andy had the
patience to say okay I got Alex Smith
here let's let this young guy learn hey
what he's done this year spectacular it
really has I mean he can throw from any
contorted position that his body gets
him into he can still throw it so he's
very very dangerous he's heady he's
competitive you can tell he's got
leadership qualities and I think he's
really he's a very very exciting player
and then though there's another one last
thing I do want to hit
Xuan is the story that was breaking at
the top of my program coach you may not
be aware of that
Carson Wentz is dealing with a back
issue and is not expected to go this
week and may not go the rest of the year
it could be Nick Foles now and just your
first blush reaction to that news for
the eagle well you know I hadn't heard
it but I will say this that this has not
been the Carson Wentz that we've seen
early on you know he's seems like he's
had issues this year that will holding
him back and you know maybe this was it
and he maybe the time will do him good
because he's a young talented guy and
you know it's it it's tough to put a guy
like that in jeopardy now you know he's
only six so many games and so many
seasons so you know when when it's
possible they should play but quite
apparently he can't so they're probably
acted wisely to give them the time
because in watching them play I don't
see the same guys so early in his career
yeah I mean and then your name was being
mentioned all throughout the Super Bowl
last year with the run that Falls went
on because of you with Hostetler as well
it looks like foals might have to do
that again well they got to get in there
first that's true you know so they got
their hands full get in there right now
don't they well I do they do I guess
they could like I said ride ride foals
again I'm wondering what you thought of
while you watch that magic carpet ride
last year coach oh hey it was special it
really was and they got it going their
defense responded the offense was
balanced they did a great job to their
credit they talked for me to say that
for the Eagles or the [ __ ] all right
all day last one for you here for I
swear my guy here Mike Dell two folks
from Jersey what
hometown Mike Livingston Livingston New
Jersey good friends with Murph that used
to guard bill when he was a coach he was
one yes security
you know Murph right coach right back in
the day look at you talk about Murph
would ya so I asked him the question you
wanted to about the the garage door I
seriously yes I mean I did it I did the
NFC Championship in 2000 in the in old
stadium did the door really get opened
for kickers was that true mess with them
with the draft let me tell you something
it really wasn't true at Giants Stadium
but it was true in Philadelphia that's
right
what do you mean that's what I saw I saw
them do it there the vet so you never
did it in Giants Stadium opening up that
door to start messing with the the cross
window I don't know I don't know who did
it
isn't someone may have done it it wasn't
it wasn't under my instruction huh so is
that some of those security people you
know no could have been Murph it is this
is great no we can't be responsible for
everybody in the state yeah it's true
that's true
hey coach you take care of yourself all
right I hope we get you to everyone I
wish you well rate him straight hit him
straight okay you got that Bill Parcells
Pro Football Hall of Famer here on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience